[Music]
boom did we just blow your mind uhhuh
well I've known the entire time when it
comes to the universe we're all
shareholders get back for your system
see we were all just little NE in a
nursery from supernovas now we've grown
into our history we're taking wi out of
mystery closure now we're taking
[Music]
itav see that's where all the balls of
gas come from hey you still look like
you're hanging on by
see the mushrooms and you'll understand
so your dust is my dust
fantastic you don't have to look too
all to figure out who you are you're a
star you know
of theep you want to know who you are
I'm a
star so I look the Stars to guide me and
every war sign I'm will be
ches but I them on one at a
time so I make this
wish something for us this so I this
wish something more for us
[Music]
this
what what are
you you kind of look
like a star okay you can't beat I mean I
know I wished on a but
no
yes this is crazy we love crazy oh I'm
seeing
[Music]
things who what are you doing Valentino
don't e
[Music]
that
it didn't work when does the magic
happen oh Something's Happened I'm
talking I am talking who knew my voice
would be this low well you're young you
don't know anything really whereas it is
my responsibility to only Grant the
wishes I am sure are good for
Roses so most of these wishes will never
be granted yet I still protect them like
all the
others can't you just give them back
instead excuse me
the wishes you're not going to Grant you
could just give them back then I don't
know the people can try to pursue them
themselves you know if they're dangerous
then they can be stopped but if they're
not you've completely missed the point
people come here because they know they
can't make their own dreams come true
the journey is too hard it is too unfair
they give their wishes to me willingly
and I make it so they forget their
worries you make it so they forget the
most beautiful part of themselves
and they don't know what they're missing
but you do and now I do it's not fair my
Saba is good the people of Rosas are
good they deserve more than I decide
what everyone
deserves I just want their wishes to
have a
chance but um look see King magnifico
has their wishes in the castle they're
captured in these ball likee bubbly
things that are very beautiful but very
locked up and he'll never give them back
what what are you doing careful my
mother was shaved for that
yarn yes that's the
castle you mean we take them back
ourselves but if we take them isn't that
stealing I mean we
can't right they don't belong to him do
they well okay
but wait wait fall down we need a plan
ah meant to do that I'm coming
bye-bye keep the name I'm magnificent I
put the eye and omnipotent I'm
passionate I'm not petulent someone
praised me for my benevolence um just
look I'd give the clothes off Benito's
back if you really needed that i' be the
first one to volunteer Henry if your
home were crumble or if you were in
trouble I'll let you live it fore free
and I don't even charge you in I clean
up all your messes and I'm always there
when you need to I give and give and
give and give you'd think they'd all be
content and all I really want is just a
little respect and this is the thanks I
get this is the I
get and this is the thanks I
get
3 2 1 Welcome to Ros come on come this
way where the greatest Creations are all
on display there's no other place just
as full of surprise where your dreams
and your reality can Collide you want to
dance on beat or to have hair touched
down to your feet go to outer space well
hey you come to the right
place here in city of
roses you can turn all your W to wishing
no worries and no
wonders oh here in the city of
Ros a home for me for you and all of us
the city of
Ros Disney's wish rated PG only in
theaters November 22nd tickets available
now your wish will never be granted You'
been deceived magn is not the man claims
to be no I'm not the only
one wait till they hear
our one thing he can't down ah it does
and the strength we found it's
too knowing what we know now knowing
what we know now
who knows it we succeed but we won't
stop and we won't Retreat
or knowing what we know now knowing what
we know now Disney's wish PG only in
theaters November 22nd 3 2 1 Asha I'm
here I'm hereo just one second let me
catch my breath Once Upon a Time the
Rosas the most Magical Kingdom founded
by a king with the power to grant wishes
you are their handsomest most beloved
King you're right I am a handsome king
I'm so nervous I think I'm going to
explode my best friend the king's
Apprentice my mouth trooping I feel like
it's
trooping Asha come with me the wi wishes
of Rosas wow people give their wishes to
me and I grant the wishes I am sure are
good for Rosas some of these will never
be granted not some most they deserve
more than I decide what everyone
deserves so I look up at the stars to
guide me I wish and throw caution to
every warning
sign oh you spoil us with your magic I
didn't do it
what last night I made a wish on a star
uh and the star
[Music]
answered I'm talking I am talking who
knew my voice would be this low I
believe I have just been threatened who
would dare threaten
you I have no response to that so I look
that there is a traitor amongst us find
Asha it's a dead end with unsanded
mahogany oh good Vine Valentino my butt
found
it I started this I have to finish
it so I make this wish what are you
hiding
nothing to be and nobody what is going
on in there okay ladies your wings can't
fire what your voice is
can this film is celebrating 100 Years
of Disney
animation and it's so special to
me starting off on wish we pined a still
from every single one of the movies
we've done on a
board you could see the breth of all the
Disney animated
[Applause]
features and this concept of Daring to
wish upon a star that resonated for all
of us W I have a few thousand questions
starting with how is any of this
possible so I look at the stars to guide
we have incredible music by Julia
Michaels bringing this really fresh Edge
and approach I mean she's worked with
Justin Bieber dualipa Selena Gomez when
I first heard the music for this film I
was so moved every single song tells
this story in a way that is so Dynamic
most of these wishes will never be
granted the people of Rosa deserve more
than I decide what everyone
[Music]
deserves that's why I wished and now
you're
here challenge
accepted I'm talking I am talking who
knew my voice voice would be this
low the dream come true to be able to
celebrate the studio and do a film that
really Embraces our Legacy but also is
looking towards the
[Music]
future oh good fine Valentino my butt
found
[Music]
[Laughter]
it